on a quand on va PIP PIP PIP
PIP tip tip le soleil je l'entends déjà
il est pas loin il est là derrière le
bois tip tip le soleil va chasser
l'hiver et l'hiver va nous jouer la
fille de l'air tip tip la couleur du
ciel a changé ce n'est plus grill et
blanc mais bleu mais alisé tip tip les
petites fleurs qui montrent le nez c'est
Monsieur winter qui les avait enterré
oh monsieur winter monsieur winter
monsieur
winter tip tip la rivière était gelé
tout ten dans la vallée
immobilisé la rivière elle estta passée
elle est passé au miser de cristallisé
tip tip la forêt se cous s grand V elle
le vaonne le prend le pas de combat tip
tip ça c'est sûr ça sent le premp et
Monsieur winter s'en va cavaler devant
oh monsieur winter monsieur winter
monsieur
winter go home oh
tip tip les moi j'enouvais plus il
restait plus de vin blanc non plus tip
tips moi j'en pouvais plus donc relire
le règlement de l'Armée du Salut tip tip
et voilà
démobilisé comme un petit repinon d
encrusé tip tip et voilà c'est tout bleu
le ciel et Monsieur winker s'en va se
fond au soleil
he monsieur winter monsieur winter
monsieur
winter Go
oh
demain peut-être après-demain
elle viendra enfin ma demoiselle de la
ville
fragile
demain peut-être après-demain
elle viendra
enfin son trîneau tiré par les
anges
étrange j'terai mon bonnet et je ferai
la révérence et puis je me
l'admirerai comme un Noël de mon
enfance demain on entrera chez moi et
puis et l'on
s'embrassera tout un
printemps
[Musique]
formidable bien bonjour monsieur le
printemps c'est la saison des amour et
je suis
content venez réchauffer mes mains et ma
tête et mon petit cœur
gelé et voilà c'est le vrai printemps et
Monsieur win va se le
C monsieur winter monsieur winter
monsieur
[Musique]
Winter et
voilà